apprendre à lire et à écrire c'est le
rôle de l'école primaire pourtant 10 à
15% des enfants en sixième ne maîtrisent
pas le langage pour jack lang s'est dès
la maternelle qu'il faut agir
l'accent doit être mis sur la pratique
de l'oral au cours élémentaire
l'apprentissage de la lecture doit se
poursuivre au delà du cp mais il faut
repérer très tôt les enfants en
difficulté des évaluations auront lieu
dès la maternelle au ce2 cm1 et cm2
l'enseignement des sciences sera rénové
moins académique davantage basé sur
l'expérimentation certains enseignements
sont renforcés les langues vivantes
devienne une discipline à part entière
dès le primaire
d'abord en cm2 à la rentrée prochaine
puis en cm1 la suivante en 2005
l'enseignement d'une langue vivante
devra commencer en maternelle
l'éducation artistique sera développée
chaque école devra notamment définir un
projet culturel et créer une chorale
enfin un effort sera fait sur les
nouvelles technologies d'ici fin 2001
toutes les écoles devront être connectés
à internet en 2003 un brevet
informatique et internet sera créé tous
les élèves devront l'avoir passé avant
de quitter l'école primaire
non